[Musique]
allah ce mur porteur là bas moi je pense
qui est qu'il doit plus porter c'est à
dire ouais s'appuie sûr il ya s'écrouler
et voici que vous approchez pourtant
reculé je vais n'en parlez pas trop
forcée les vibrations ça peut tout
non moi en fait ce que je veux c'est
vraiment un simple rafraîchissement
c'était en fait voilà je l'accompagné
mont blanc blanc basique c'est beaucoup
de pression basic basique donc blanc
pour vous c'est basique il ya cinquante
murs de blanc sur blanc nacré blanc de
blanc blanc cassé non espagnol italien
pas je vais pour faire tous les pays et
du coup pour mon salon ça reviendrait à
combien je vous fais une petite vie bah
ouais
ouais ça fait quoi
j'ai tiré un peu les prix eux l'été est
là c'est pour moi merci de ses
excuses à monsieur en fait je vous ai
pas demandé d'aidé pour l'immeuble c'est
juste pour le salon ah oui nous le
savons il entraîne un rafraîchissement
voulait pas que je vous fasse une pub
sur instagram j'ai un peu connus sujet
je suis suivi par pendantes devant sur
quoi ou une fugue sur instagram jeu par
votre entreprise est comme ça vous
gagnez des gens et puis ils viennent
mais en tant que client que ces échanges
de bons procédés c'est quoi donc on ne
sait pas non mais je fais pas de
politique cette fois snapshot banon je
bois pas d'alcool du smictom un bon je
vais bien de rigoler
facebook après facebook je connais ah
mais c'est pas à vous avez la télé
monsieur ouais j'ai une petite télé en
noir et blanc ça me suffit c'est déjà un
début de cataracte donc voila tu es déjà
regardé comme ça je suis j'ai fermé je
suis obligée de fermer dès que je vois
il a dit c'est ça le défi garder la
connaît pour voir quand nous avons
regardé
changer d'avis après avoir bu on est bon
là dessus alors allez faire conclut on
parle on parle a par contre vu demander
d art d z'arts pas des espaces dès
aujourd'hui des arrhes d'une avance
c'est légal ah oui pas de problème on
espère signer puisque je prends plus la
carte
merci à l'oubli
[Musique]